[Musique]
jean louis trintignant a la réputation
d'être un solitaire il tient à cette
réputation est peut-être est-ce pour
cela qu'il cherche une maison à la
campagne dans une île de bretagne
[Musique]
s'est installée de 12
deux partis non c'est un grenier partent
et 9 avaient capturé ce qui contredit
pas
[Musique]
pourquoi venir acheter une maison dans
une île en bretagne parce qu'une livre
c'est quand même un endroit très
difficile pour y veiller
et c'est un endroit qui va rester très
longtemps
c'était
et
wesley falaise se refaisant
des choses simples et belles et naturel
de la vie
fait que vous saviez exactement ce que
vous vouliez
moi j'ai toujours suspect
façon j'ai comme ça pas du tout
ambitieux ni débrouillard mais
comme vous êtes libre dans la vie
vous savez quand on court un comédien
s'est donc on travaille on est vrai
par exemple quand on tourne on est sous
contrat pendant deux mois ou trois mois
pour le même film
on est obligé d'être raccord c'est à
dire que l'on peut pas arriver le matin
au studio avec un oeil au beurre noir
par exemple je suis pas du tout
bagarreur mais enfin si un type ne
provoque dans la rue et m'ennuie et je
peux pas me battre j'ai pas le droit
parce que le film sera arrêté j'ai pas
le droit de me faire casser la figure
pendant la fille ne s'est peut-être pas
grand-chose mais enfin c'est il faut
faire attention il faut pas prendre de
risque on peut pas faire le fou en
voiture j'ai pas du tout l'intention de
me casser la figure en voiture les
prélats
[Musique]
émané le principe d'une voiture
pour rester sur la route
et bien conduire c'est arrivé à faire
bâtir sur la route
il ya du gravillon fall et mollo c'est
[Musique]
famille à l'âge c'est pas bien free a
bien pris la trajectoire
gérald ans j'aurais départ car je suis
un fils très très affectueux j'ai
beaucoup de tendresse pour eux ça fait
15 ans que je les ai quittés et genre
écrire régulièrement deux fois par
semaine c'est beaucoup et et bien non si
vous lisez tous les articles qu'on écrit
sur votre fils
j'ai besoin en bourgogne et atouts à
même quand je jouais dans une pièce à la
radio si les manceaux journal
est ce que vous pourriez nous les
montrer ses cahiers nous imposant on
recueille des articles importants puis à
des trucs petites choses oui et on rase
tout ce qu est l équipe à ce niveau ce
moment mais il est sorti diana des
petits bouts à la grêle et mais en fait
quelques euros voir cette belle entame
nous sommes enfin il a fait que des
progrès est ce que vous êtes content de
ce qu'il est devenu
comme dans ça sinon je suis ravi et
enchanté même je fais beaucoup de choses
pour pour eux par exemple de la
télévision de la radio s'est platement
pour autant fait pour parce que ils
peuvent avoir la maison fin ils ont pas
ce que je fais au théâtre à paris ils
peuvent pas le voir les films mis les
voir enfin ma mère des enfants et mon
père des voix dans éclats la radio c'est
c'est bien
des polos à des polos mais bien sûr
monsieur alors là vous avez des polos de
toutes les tailles
je tends pas voilà les prolos c'est là
ça et laisser le 3 c'est moi c'est bien
tu as essayé de oui non oui c'est vrai
c'est un peu comme passer un si joli
safran-ge ses crises de larmes lorsque
l'on voit la sarthe produire dans une
famille quand on aura encore vous aviez
besoin leur fait un choix délicat tout
cas merci je vais attendre il a bouclé
les voix il tandis que toi tu exprimes
assumant chermiti l'état lycée fermat
n'y avait personne c'est une merde
la beauté des cafés les bars hiver la
femme plus de soutiens gorge c'est vrai
mais c'est récent oui ça s'est fait sans
soutien-gorge eurobloc ont comparé les
soutiens-gorge qu'est ce que ça veut
dire
voilà c'est merveilleux nom n'a pas vu
nos maillots américain je vais prendre
un verre et un tout c'est merveilleux
c'est my own on regarde sa couronne à
palpable que j'ai pas de maillot pour
objet que de beau pantalon et du dam du
pk lile enchères fait carré du port cet
orage vous dire que je prends un verre
et un comme ça
chez toi
[Musique]
dans le corps alex timidement et la
participation des cavaliers rend à
chypre
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
que d'emprunter avec les lions
nous sommes ni cannes
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
vous appelez visiblement givet
mettez vous un petit peu de chances
qu'on aperçoit que vous aimez
une pièce non mais
mais vous savez 30 ans en juillet
vous laissez pas quelque chose tout le
monde serait content et super rock
énergie parce que j'ai beaucoup voyagé
germaneau
matériel pourquoi
[Musique]
hélas
il me fallait vous êtes quoi tous trois
points assez bien ce kit année la
tendance à bouder hockey le broker qui
pense pas que je force vraiment à les
faire
les improvisations comme ça avec les
gens qui me force pour prouver
on savait pas naturel enfin je suis pas
tellement un acteur spontané chez un
acteur
je dirais pas pas du tout intellectuel
mais qui enfin je suis pas un acteur
doué je suis pas un acteur une nature
comment vous définiriez alors eh bien
comme acteur comme acteur maman
[Musique]
je sais pas je suis plutôt je serais
plutôt un acteur
metteur en scène c'est à dire que tard
dans bel ami mien c'est non non mais
j'ai plutôt dans un film je me pense
qu'il a plutôt comme un collaborateur du
metteur en scène comme un
préférez trajet est ce que les acteurs
viennent de milieux bourgeois
oui en grande partie v
qu'est-ce que ça les limites pas dans
leur rôle si cet exo exactement
je pense que il ya certains personnages
qui sont en fait très peu de films
sur le milieu ouvrier parce que
il ya très peu d'acteurs qui viennent
même s'ils s'en viennent ils ont
yeah et il ya surtout en plus très peu
des metteurs en scène qui viennent d'un
milieu
c'est un problème qui est qu'ils peuvent
aborder difficilement c'est dommage et
pourquoi dans le cinéma américain par
exemple les acteurs sont capables
d'interpréter à peu près tous les rôles
c'est une vache les deux acteurs
français non je pense pas que les
acteurs mairie a réussi à aborder que
les rôles
puisque les acteurs français n'arrivent
pas jouer des rôles de
veuillez
personnage 2002 moyens par exemple non
c'est pas tellement vrai je crois pas
non plus que les acteurs américains n'y
a pas tellement de crimes sur
le milieu ouvrier en amérique ou alors
ce sont pas vraiment des acteurs ou
alors il ya eu quelques films mais
c'était à une autre époque où le cinéma
demander moins de réalisme qui
maintenant maintenant un poste de la
télévision les gens sont habitués à une
vérité un réalisme auquel il n'était pas
habitué à vent et par exemple les films
américains comme je sais pas ce qu'ils
ont été tirés des romans de steinbeck
comme les raisins de la colère par
exemple c'était henry fonda qui joue un
rôle de d'ouvriers on admettait
maintenant là ne mettrai plus
l'admettront l'admettait à l'époque jeux
conçus sûrement là ne mettrai plus
est ce qu'il y à un personnage qui vous
a marqué que j'aimais beaucoup que j'ai
joué oui
hamlet ou et bien sûr ça personnage
tellement riche tellement complexe que
j'ai travaillé un an la première fois
que je les jouais et depuis je j'y pense
tout le temps pas tout le temps tout le
temps mais enfin il se passe pas de
semaine sans que je relise la pièce ou
sans que je cherche par rapport aux
personnages des choses nouvelles
je vais le rejouer bientôt mais pourquoi
particulièrement omelette parce que
c'est le personnage le plus riche le
plus complexe qu'on puisse imaginer
je crois pas que dans le théâtre il ya
peut-être d'autres personnages m'enfin
pour moi c'est le personnage qui est
abordable pour moi et qui finalement est
tellement tellement riche ci est toute
ma vie de comédien je la consacre à
jouer bien
hamlet une fois ce sera déjà merveilleux
qu'est ce qui vous intéresse
particulièrement dans ce rôle ton talent
qu'il est
et bien c'est d'abord la première fois
que j'ai joué j'étais tout jeune j'étais
plus jeune que le rôle et ce qui
m'intéressait c'était d'en faire un anti
héros et de le jouer pas du tout
romantique
c'est à dire moi j'ai imaginé que
c'était un un type un garçon petit
prince comme ça un peu médiocre un peu
éteint qui tout d'un coup à la
révélation extraordinaire que son père a
été assassiné par son oncle et son père
lui dit venge - et ce petit type qui n'a
rien d'un héros qui est un type très
moyen tout d'un coup devient un
personnage de tragédie et essaie
d'accomplir son acte et il grandit il
grandit et il devient finalement enfin
il accomplit son acte et après il
devient une sorte de dark en disant que
pour moi c'était un objecteur de
conscience quoi est ce que vous aimez
agit en dessous un peu comme hamlet
oui mais je suis confiant ça m'amuse
c'est à dire c'est un jeu mais j'aime
bien que la fourberie
j'aime bien mentir gratuite oui je
trouve que moi je vous ment pas assez
d'ailleurs
et ça vous amuse pourquoi vous montez
comme ça ça ça m'amuse parce que j'aime
pas les rapports finalement tout ce qui
est tout d'une pièce ça m'ennuie parce
qu'on en fait le tour très vite
alors j'aime bien j'aime pas les gens
qui après dix minutes qu'on a parlé avec
eux on les connaît c'est plus ennuyeux
quoi parce qu'ils sont comme ça alors
j'aime bien les gens qui vous
surprennent quoi vous avez intérêt à
face l île nature qu'on fait oui
on ne remet rien pour les yeux
d'habitude là on leur cache pas les yeux
non c'est vrai que les chevaux voit
beaucoup plus grand et nous voir il
paraît trois fois comme on est pour ça
qu on les impressionne tu vois voilà
[Applaudissements]
est ce que vous considérez acteurs c'est
un métier alors oui c'est un métier très
raisonnable enfin une dignité se trouve
ça dépend si on est acteur pour pour se
faire photographier enfin c'est pas
c'est humiliant c'est imbécile mais si
on est acteur moi je considère qu'un
acteur c'est un collaborateur du metteur
en scène et si on prend ce métier comme
ça c'est très très estimable c'est un
créateur dans le domaine qui lui est
réservé comme un metteur en scène et un
créateur raconte une histoire est bien
en aide
le metteur en scène a raconté l'histoire
le mieux possible donc sous sept ans
vous considérez qu'acteur c'est un
métier mais pourtant vous avez dit dans
l'île pour moi acteur c'est pas un
métier
si ça oui vous savez les gens qui se
contredisent jamais sans général des
imbéciles ce que vous avez tout fait
pour devenir acteur on hésite un peu
malgré moi que je devenir acteur c'est à
dire que
je voulais être metteur en scène un
départ pour moi c'est pas indispensable
je pourrais vivre sans être comédien
j'ai pas besoin de jouer il ya des
comédiens qui ont un besoin de jouer
moi pas ça nous sommes
ça m'intéresse énormément mais j'ai pas
besoin j'ai pas un besoin physique de
deux d'être en représentation ce que
vous pensez pas qu un acteur doit
pouvoir interpréter n'importe quel rôle
non pas n'importe quel rôle un acteur
doit pouvoir se déplacer c'est à dire
interpréter une gamme de personnages qui
sont un peu différents de lui je crois
pas à la composition je crois pas qu'on
puisse de a à z composer un personnage
et se faire une idée d'un personnage et
le composent et même si vous est opposé
je crois que l'inter doit s'enrichir le
plus possible pour avoir une gamme la
plus étendue possible mais quand même
dans une certaine limite
vous n'avez jamais joué des personnages
forts crève l'écran
oui parce que je suis pas ça je sais
quand même mes limites et je sais que je
peux pas jouer un personnage comme ça un
héros enfin parce que je suis pas ça du
tout je suis pas un personnage fort ni
briand et je peux avoir d'autres
qualités enfin qui sont plus discrètes
plus complexe c'est certain que j'ai
jamais joué le personnage ferait
changerai jamais dans votre métier
qu'est ce qui vous intéresse ce qui
m'intéresse c'est
c'est
c'est curieux parce que quand j'étais
petit il ya une chose qui me fascine et
j'ai jamais été très mystique mais ma
mère m'a mené à l'église et j'étais
fasciné par le le monsieur qui prêchait
et j'étais fasciné par le l'histoire du
christ enfin finalement c'est très
simple s'il sait très naïf et mais je
trouve le la plus belle réussite de
comédiens c'est le christ enfin c'est le
type qui a pu parler à des milliers de
personnes et leur apporter le la grâce
ou labonté et c'est finalement le métier
de comédien c'est d'apporter aux gens
des émotions de les rendre peut-être
enfin plus sensibles à certaines choses
dans l'absolu c'est ce qui est beau dans
ce métier dans toute création d'ailleurs
chez un artiste peintre aussi si une
toile peut toucher les gens c'est très
beau et ce qui me déplaît un peu c'est
le ses longs doigts quand même pour être
comédien s'analyser un peu trop ça ça me
gêne un peu de il faut se connaître ça
me gêne un peu de monsieur de me
connaître
quel est votre trait de caractère
principal
enfin on dit toujours les petits défauts
ce tir et la timidité pour moi c'est un
grand défaut et
une qualité l'eau n'a d'idée peut-être
vous avez une certaine façade est ce que
cette façade ne cache pas une certaine
férocité de notre part oui
non j'ai bien sûr j'adore jouer au poker
et le poker pour moi c'est un moyen de
me défouler de tout ce que j'ai de
mauvais en moins par exemple je peux
être prêt poker et j'aime bien
d'ailleurs pas pour le résultat mais au
moment où je le fais ça m'amuse toujours
la cruauté over ça me stimule énormément
par exemple quand au poker et qu'un
joueur a déjà beaucoup perdu
on appelle ça en dit la tête dans le sac
enfin qu'il est complètement anéanti
moi j'aime bien le massacre et le point
et c'est terrible c'est moche c'est metz
15 d'affreux 25
car ils disent oh la vache
je crois que vous allez le faire
après quand dieu quand on fait les
comptes et qui doit me donner de
l'argent ça m'intéresse plus ça me gêne
j'ai plus la priorité à ce moment là
rires oui l4 qu'avant tout c'est sur 400
villes mais au moment où je le coin 51
ça m'amuse énormément
le poker est un jeu de méchanceté et ça
m'intéresse d'aller chercher la
perfection dans la méchanceté dans un
film vous avez joué un rôle
antipathique d'un homme de droite pour
être dire assez violent presque lâche
est-ce que vous aimiez à ce moment-là
interpréter ce rôle pour coup richetin
c'est un des rôles peut-être même le
rôle que j'ai préféré ça m'intéressait
d'abord parce que le personnage était
condamnable au départ et ça
m'intéressait de le défendre
on
[Musique]
vous pensez vraiment ne pas être en
accord avec ces personnages moralement
et psychologiquement
non non mais si je peux jouer un
personnage de [ __ ] c'est que
je me comporte pas enfin j'essaie je
crois que je ne me comporte pas comme un
[ __ ] dans la vie mais c'est que je les
en moins c'est que ça mais pas
franchement étrange et oui je fais ça
parce que ça ne serait pas possible de
jouer je crois pas non non non
[Musique]